مشاهد مليئه بالحب والتضحيه لحاجه السوريه
تساعد زوجها المقعد على اداء فريضه الحج
السيده وزوجها مشاهدينا القادمان من شمال
سوريا سعيا الى تحقيق حلمهما بالحج سويا
حيث تبذل الزوجه الكثير من الجهد لاعانه
زوجها الذي لم ينسى معروفها كما سنشاهد في
هذا الفيديو
[موسيقى]
اسمي نضال احمد انا من سوريا هي زوجتي وهي
اللي يعني بعد اصابتي والحمد لله رب
العالمين صوتي يعني
تساعدني بكل اعمالي اليوميه الحمد لله رب
العالمين
يعني اعمال اللي تحتاج اكل خدمه شخصيه حتى
احيانا دفع العرب الحمد لله انا كمان احسن
امشي يعني مسافات بسيطه ممكن يعني واحد
كيلو اثنين كيلو الحمد لله رب العالمين بس
احيانا اريح نفسي مشان ما يصير جهد على
الاطراف والله يعني وجودها الحمد لله الله
سبحانه وتعالى اكرمنا بالوصول للحج يعني
وقضاء هذا المنسك العظيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين
[موسيقى]